manifestaciones como estas son
habituales en la capital Argentina en
esta ocasión fueron miles de personas de
organizaciones que representan a
sectores de bajos ingresos con empleos
precarios o que se sostienen con ayuda
Estatal que consideran insuficiente
no alcanza si bien A mí tampoco me
alcanza yo pago un alquiler y yo creo
que ninguno de los compañeros que están
acá tampoco les alcanza yo pues tienen
hijos tienen cuatro cinco seis chicos
cada uno y no les alcanza el economista
guido Zack explica que en un país con
casi 40% de pobreza y precios que
aumentaron más de 108% en los últimos 12
meses la alta inflación no impacta igual
en toda la sociedad esto se ve
claramente en el mercado laboral entre
el segmento informal y el segmento
formal el segmento formal que en general
tienen un salario promedio más elevado
es un segmento que es más que mal sigue
la inflación y no tiene tanta pérdida
por adquisitivo el sector informal tiene
una pérdida de poder adquisitivo muy
significativa sin embargo el empleo en
el sector informal es el que más ha
crecido segmento del que forma parte
Pablo Julián Romero con algo de ayuda
Pablo comenzó un emprendimiento de
producción y venta de empanadas él es un
ejemplo de lo que le ha ocurrido a
muchos pasó del empleo formal y la
seguridad económica la informalidad
laboral y a vivir con lo justo del 2015
a esta parte que son 8 años
Yo fui como una la pendiente fue para
abajo Nunca fue para así que podría
haber sido y así no siempre fue
linealmente para abajo en mi caso hablo
Pablo tiene mucha expectativa de que el
negocio de las empanadas le permita
salir adelante y trata de no pensar en
la inestabilidad económica del país y la
amenaza que representa para proyectos
como el suyo